but uh but anyway this is about the
evils of science so I think it's perfect
[Music]
my oh my rock and fire
who's the apple of my eye why it's my
very own drove me oh if I should stroll
the hood who knew I could look so good
just talking on the phone just say by
day our DNA this is the Olsen twins -
we'll survive
side by side mother nature don't you
call her for me she's my blow me was
wealthy but not healthy had no one to
dwell with me so look who I got Bo
clothed me far from broke bored rich
folk we don't need no natural yoke that
babies come for me we'll get a publicist
and show them be the most lovable things
cancer cells I'm a ninth
inspector will survive side by side
should have signed with verve instead of
soul
Oh Clooney how I love you I'm the only
person I ever loved
gee that's swell I guess you're just my
fatal attraction
[Music]
[Applause]
you